when did you lose your virginity 13 oh
[__] was that like what's the story and
what was his
name her name it was it was a chick
Filipino chick in Hawaii everybody
Filipino we did it in her dad's bed W
this feels crazy I was like this is nice
you know oh ra this is kind of good
slippery how'd you know what you were
doing it was natural the first time I
figured out about coming was cuz my
Grandpa would be in his room smoking
cigarettes watching porn with a vibrator
what the [__] yeah he was in his bed
every day and I was like yo what are you
doing like oh sh kind a vibrator is a
masser it was mass yo one day my grandpa
left and I was
like what's going on here I don't know
anyone that smokes cigarettes and jacks
off at the same time but then for my
lady it was just like you know when you
rub dick on their butt you're like
oh is it time that's when I first found
out